What if you could build something which can transmit the highest amounts of data,...
...like a fiber, but wirelessly.
So, it takes less than 10 minutes to set up...
...and can be nearly infinitely scalable in terms of information.
And that's how this device came about.
Yeah, so you culminated in this?
This is kind of like the size of a small shoe box.
It weighs less than three kilograms.
It's capable of replacing those very expensive fibers...
...on a city level or on a country level.
As the push toward 5G heats up,...
...fast and reliable connectivity is especially crucial for business.
While Singapore ranks as a global leader for internet connectivity,...
...much of Southeast Asia is still catching up.
By 2025, the region is expected to account for almost a third of global 5G deployments.
Rohit wants to make sure that coverage is evenly distributed.